hi folks I do you enjoying you three
it's almost over to lap up the last of
it two more games one more VR game is
the year VR i'm donny to irene's here
Brian tight how you doing sir I'm doing
great good to have you here I wonder
what video game you're gonna talk to us
about I could not possibly tell ya
there's a little hint right here but
Star Trek bridge crew yes this is a very
interesting sort of surprised we didn't
have we got a lot of sprite eventually
we got a lot of surprises yes a favor
for a while there we were hearing leaks
of all of them right with one with such
a prestigious brand associated with it
it was a really wonderful that we didn't
get any excited this one so
congratulations first of all thank you
nice work and yeah what's it like been
been working on this it's been amazing
it's a dream come true to work on the
Star Trek franchise and here is your fav
captain oh he had to go there did ya
straight away alright well ok so I grew
up odd one of my first play sets i got
for christmas yeah was the original
series bridge which i don't think i was
doing it right i would mash that up with
my sister's toys yeah so Donny and Marie
Osmond would be on the bridge along with
you with Kirkland so Kirk was my first
look a right but then I think I started
to gravitate more towards Picard later
in life you know that's what i was
watching in high school and college but
Jane Wayne Cisco never I look in oruro i
know i love them too but you know i'm a
Kirk or Picard guy ok fair enough so
bridge crew for people who don't know
what it is and to me it reminds a game
that I love playing on my phone called
space team oh you're working at a bunch
a yeah and it I instantly thought oh my
god it's not but you can actually look
around this end right wonderful idea is
that close enough to wait on that's not
a bad way to compare cuz uh you do get
when you're playing like four players
right can get pretty crazy and
everybody's yelling at each other like
oh my god get the shields up get the
shields up so a little bit like space
seem that way but it's it's really um
you know it's it's a you're actually
flying the starship
you know it you're not just yelling
orders at each other or anything like
that you're doing it you're actually you
know working the controls get the
helmsman piloting the ship you got the
tactical officer working the weapons and
shields and the engineer keeping
everything running the captain the
smartest guy in the room coordinating
everybody it did feels like the real
deal awesome and so there's four
different people playing in coop right
yo it's up to four players right so you
can play it solo okay you can play as
the captain giving orders to AI crew
members I and if you just really want to
take take the seat like you like to fire
the torpedoes yeah you can jump on the
tactical station and operate the weapons
then go back to the captain's chair uh
but the it's the control freak captain
of all time yes looking on my crotch yes
one man band that's right that's right
but my favorite way to play is with with
four friends right you know or actually
at e3 you know three strangers has been
an amazing experience playing with
random groups of people having a blast
is there any online components and I'm
multiplayer because absolutely there is
as well so it's not like you have to
drag in 30 you don't have to come to a
cramped little booth at e3 and squeeze
in there no dough you could play from
the comfort of your own home how would
that work with that match people up
Fleck who are like on the same
augustine's experience level as you or
like how does that work well we will
have a matchmaking system if you don't
have you know a full set of friends to
play with but you you can also you know
play using friends lists and then sort
of thing if you want a more controlled
scenario it's it's fascinating because
you're if you if you're playing with
random people oftentimes there's a sort
of a oftentimes there's a singular goal
but everyone's having like
one-upsmanship thing we're like I'm
going to be better than everyone else
but in a scenario like this right you
have to work together exactly it's not
like you can be the best helmsman in the
world right I'm like everyone else just
falls apart right it's gonna be a
fascinating like I wonder if you guys
can even like listen in on those to see
like strangers from around the world
getting on for the same as ship force to
be nice to be right there yeah just all
creeping listen in on other people
sessions or something it would be fun
because we're so same yes absolutely so
what are you doing like what are they
small enclosed levels like multiple
was I mostly combat is their exploration
like what you actually sort of doing in
the levels well there's got to be combat
in Star Trek right but combat is never
the purpose of your mission you're right
you know Starfleet is not out there to
blow people up but inevitably you know
some people still got blown up yeah so
people are gonna get blown up but the
idea is that you're given a goal like
you might be given you might have a
rescue mission you might be on an
exploration mission but if you do run
into opposition you as a crew are going
to decide what to do about it are you
going to fight you're going to try and
run them off you're going to try and
kill them you decide how to deal with
that graduation but I mean the crew can
fight amongst themselves about like we
should actually go in well there's one
person driving the ship the help Alvin
drives it he has a little pal he or she
has all the power but everybody has a
lot of power it actually takes the whole
group working together because the
helmsman has to get you to your
objectives all right the tactical
officers scanning things and you know
locking on the enemy ship and firing
torpedoes up so if you want to fight the
tactical officers got to join in right
right and everybody depends on the
engineer as well he's allocating power
and figuring out who needs what
resources into given time and keeping
the ship repaired transporting people if
you're on a rescue mission right and
that kind of thing and the captain is as
we say that the smartest guy in the room
the captain has more information about
the situation than any of the other
players so the captain is the best one
to keep everybody coordinated and let
them know what our priorities should be
like you know here's how we should do
this guy's but it's a social game right
it's you're really on a starship with
other people so yeah it'll argue about
it you know they argue about how to deal
with it you know the captain's like
lower shields and technical officers
like no rudder fire this happens a lot I
love the idea that like the captain like
they're the the you know they're he or
she is like trying to like control all
these people but unlike you know the
show they can't just like relieve the
engineer I feel like to move over West
movie doesn't work that way yeah all for
the big big time here and I'll get
somebody else on there and what so I
guess the other aspect of this is this
is a virtual reality game absolutely
cool that there's all this like you know
to see like folks like red Sauron like
Ubisoft sort of getting involved in
virtuality and trying to make these
expiry
ranges is there a non viewer version of
this now it's a virtuality only
experience right it's really about being
on a starship and that's something that
doesn't sort of come across when we have
these conversations right a lot of the
time like our you know when we shall be
roller you guys your trailers or
whatever right look like so is there
like a sort of a different are you
turning around to look at people and I
yes you're like yeah tell me talk about
that sort of aspect like why virtuality
sort of okay requirement with the first
eye-popping moment when we demo for
people is like if the captain's like you
know taking hey take a look around and
you know I'm right here behind you and
people like oh my god the captain is
right there you can see everything I'm
doing and that's just the first of many
eye-popping moments that right laughs
when that they're playing the game but
it's it's all of its just like we're
here you know talking to each other face
to face when you're playing in a social
VR experience it's like we're actually
on the starship together right you know
looking at each other talking to each
other gesturing dance moves seem to be
really popular getting at e3 see a lot
of raising the roof when people are
playing ahead of the controls work of is
it dualshock 4 we're talking about or
now the the ultimate way to play the
game is with hand tracking controls all
right with the vibe or move with
PlayStation VR or with oculus touch
right in doing with demoing with oculus
touch really 283 so yeah so people
really get to get into it yeah do this
kind of stuff yeah yeah that's fast but
but you can also play with the gamepad
we want to make sure that as many people
as possible can play the game you just
don't get to do you know call to do this
when you're talking with the gamepad
that's amazing I didn't realize that
oculus touch we're doing game that I
used that Gamescom last year and it's
like it was incredible yes like oh my
god like to have that tall man have
control over like individual digits is
yessir vendors and so I guess I got I'm
super fast me about it I guess another
thing that I'm very it is like the audio
in this when you're talking with people
especially if it's online is the audio
spatial so like you can you hear the
captain over your shoulder or is right
like comms and call a duty where you can
like hear people well I know I'm so glad
you asked because most people think they
immediately just think about the visuals
when they take well virtually but sound
is just as important and our audio team
has been working so hard and doing such
an amazing job on the spatialization of
the audio
to make sure the sound is really like
you're there and that really helps you
communicate with other players you can
really tell you know when they've got
the sound spatial age just right and the
levels are mixed just so you can really
tell who's talking where it's coming
from and it's not like you know like
your conventional party chat where
everybody is just talking in your ear
you can really make out individual
voices when everybody is screaming all
right you know it's an absolutely
essential part of the experience so yeah
I'm presumably as well you get to hear
like the nuance sort of like panic in
like so much noise as well oh absolutely
and I and I have to say we've had a
great relationship with with a CBS since
we're getting worked on this and they've
been providing nice I totally forgot yes
yes the family that's right right that's
the CBS hooks us up with all the assets
we need for the you know to produce the
look and sound of the game right so when
we got the actual authentic sounds of a
Federation starship got them in
spatialized audio on the bridge it was
just ok this is moment I just going to
close my eyes that's amazing and I'm
just going to enjoy the ambience cuz I'm
really there how much freedom do you
have with that kind of stuff I mean like
Star Trek tisn't established universally
liked do you have to stick very very
closely to all the little details that
make it what it is well I I think you
probably know that the fans of Star Trek
are very very passionate right now I've
met so many people at e3 you know
walking around with a shirt of people
stopping me I love Star Trek let me tell
you about my love of Star Trek yeah so
we know that me this is that we love it
too and this is a brand we've got to get
right you know we can't we can't mess up
so authenticity is really important to
us just to make sure that we get the
look the the sound the lore all has to
be right so that's part of that
relationship with with CBS is like if we
don't know the answers to something
about Star Trek we go right to the
source and they set us up with whoever
we need in order to get to get the
official answer to anything about Star
Trek and that's awesome this probably
like a dedicated star chick like person
story and everything yes there is
serious am I guess what oh good another
question I have a bad sort of speaking
to that is like what era are we talking
about here okay the game is
in the alternate timeline that you you
see in the reboot movie right okay so
that's the most visually spectacular
version of Star Trek lots of those
players yet there's ones first yes it's
perfect for VR yeah good stuff and I've
another question about that as well
because I we were it's weird that two
interviews in a row we bring up rich
gallop used to be the person who used to
host off a game spot but he's the EP on
Star Trek timelines okay I remember
having a conversation with him about you
like audio vaults that they have yes
like you can literally like scrub to a
like particular episode right like they
can lift they're like warps voice yes
like they have all guess what's up and
like work oh the resource is amazing
it's like we were like kids in a candy
store right when the digital asset
started coming and all that all the
sounds all the you know the reference
footage from sets and everything you
know down to individual decals on on
panels so right yeah yes it's it's
amazing the wealth of material available
it's amazing just having your lcars wet
dream sorry wrong century I know oh yeah
your choice is the name of my
autobiography and did you go back and
play any old Star Trek games like I
think about all the great first-person
games that we enjoyed backlight right
you know but it's experiencing the
bridge you know I mean like yeah like
the Voyager games the right with a
relief force yes right yeah that's you
go back and have a look at those and
sort of you know honestly I haven't
played them in a long time right the
older Star Trek games you know a lot of
people mentioned Star Trek bridge
commander there five course yeah as a
you know a point of comparison but
really we started fresh with this
concept I mean Star Trek is the the
original inspiration it's not really
based on any other game or Star Trek
game you know we just go we go straight
to our star trek fantasy and how we want
to bring it to life any easter eggs in
the game well i can't spoil I presumably
I stood up point the engineers and
everything that they're there slifer's
you're not actually stepping into the
you're not you're not Clark are you oh
this is about your voice okay right so
yes you you create a character
a Starfleet officer and you go on your
own voyage with a new ship ok SS Aegis
first of her class right yes with with
some experimental new technology that we
we will reveal later every time you blow
up does it add like a letter to the you
just circle back after 26 or whatever
there you go I'll take that under a [ __ ]
so obviously the people within the
within your your your bridge are you
know unfamiliar folks but you know will
you be going to familiar missions will
it be like people you know from other
Klingons and Ferengi's and things like
that there's going to be a lot that's
going to be familiar about the setting
it is it there's a new story to be told
here and then there's also procedural
missions so like randomly generated
mission so we want to make sure that
there's always like a sense of
exploration that going into the unknown
because that's part about the heart of
Star Trek so you can roll a random
mission and nobody will have played this
one before right oh wow but we'll have
more to reveal about the story later in
the year lovely soft yeah when are we
going to see it released I guess bro
this fall for oculus rift in HTC vive
and PlayStation VR good stuff
congratulations thank you on this is I
guess did you ever think like when you
were working for we've been working for
Red Storm for Louis yeah yeah so and
you've been a Star Trek fan separately
to that yes when did when the stars
align what was that like I was amazing
it was amazing you know we we started
with our social VR technology our
provide and we discovered the magic of
being in virtual worlds with other
people and and trying to figure out what
what would be the ultimate thing we
could do with this and almost the first
idea we came up with was Star Trek right
we won't probably want to fly and
starship yeah and but we didn't think it
would happen you know but you know we
took it to CBS we showed them our
technology and pitch them the game ideas
Nate they were instant fans and in fact
they said basically this was the star
trek game that they always wanted right
happen and then levar burton is
basically saying that on this I was not
like oh that was amazing as amazing is
that better play with Lavar today was
did you really it's a bit weird him
putting a headset
yeah like that I know kind of visor yeah
exactly Geordi LaForge of 2016 that's
right wonderful stuff congratulations on
the project and thank you best of luck
with the rest for Brian thank you so
much for coming on thank you very much
yes today we are almost done folks here
on the gamespot's 83 2016 the electronic
trip we're almost done for another year
it feels like it's been going on for 48
days we have myself section at the end
of today's show but our favorite games
of e3 are actually our favorite game of
you three but before that we have we
have another little surprises here with
our star trek surprise we also have a
zombie surprise in the face of days gone
we're going to get some of the folks who
are involved in that on the stage in
just a few minutes to talk to us about
that get your questions in the chat
you're going to be keeping an eye on
dash back in two minutes you're watching
the game spot stage brought to you by
airheads bites